hello everybody good morning to you
energy bills are rising to new record
highs from today piling more misery on
millions of people already struggling
with the soaring cost of living
Charities are warning of unaffordable
energy costs for many households despite
government support
prices are still double what they were
last winter and the increase comes at a
time of higher inflation as well as
rising interest rates so let's take a
look at the details now and the cap for
the average household in England Wales
and Scotland were set to rise to
3549 pounds a year from today but it's
been frozen at 2 500 pounds for typical
energy bills for two years under the
government's energy price guarantee
which was announced last month
that replaces the
1971 pound price cap that applied
between April and September
households will also see the first
installment of the 400 pound Energy bill
discount in their October bill
many people simply can't afford to heat
their homes but as Tom Parmenter reports
warm spaces have been created across the
country to help them through the winter
thank you
if you needed another indicator of where
this cost of living crisis is taking us
it's here in the Players Lounge at
greenside Cricket Club 20 degrees
and that'll mean you've got a warm space
warm space just in the borough of
gateshead there are 65 venues opening
their doors for people
somewhere warmer than their own homes
this winter
it's Victorian isn't it it's a bit odd
it's just something I've never thought
of or expected
Society it's just a huge thing like that
there's people not even just people you
know on Universal Credit going to
struggle it's a it's it is universal
everybody's going to struggle it's just
tedious really and I'm just so pleased
that we can do this
People's Energy bills are just one part
of the puzzle the clubhouse here already
doubles as a weekly Food Market three
pounds buys you The Pick of what's on
offer
you don't really care when you're seven
months old but Lena's mum is feeling it
I think the fact that people are gonna
have to come here to sit to be warm I
mean come on it's like it's getting a
bit ridiculous
Jess is hoping she won't need to come
here for heat but they're expecting that
many others will
and this is happening all over the UK
and quite simply it's never been needed
before and the problem that all of these
venues have got is that quite often when
people leave them they'll still be going
back to cold homes
the UK government has intervened and
limited the rises in household energy
bills along with various discount
schemes but for so many families it
still isn't enough when the price of
everything else is soaring
so we predict that by January as many as
many as two and three households could
be really struggling with essential
household expenses now that's a terrible
number it's I think it equates to
something like 24 million households as
a network we're expecting a tsunami of
demand to come through our door they
will do what they can but people here
don't want warm spaces they want warm
homes they want to live not just to
survive inside a Cricket Club
Tom Parmenter Sky News gateshead
tens of thousands of rail workers have
walked out for 24 hours and the biggest
rail strike in decades as an ongoing pay
dispute continues the action is expected
to shut down most of the country's
Railway Network causing disruption for
millions of commuters the strikes are
the latest in a year marked by
widespread labor unrest
so let's take a look at the strikes in a
bit more detail well today's round of
industrial action is the first of three
planned for October rail workers from
the rmt asleff and tssa unions will be
walking out across the UK 14 train
operators will be affected with many
running reduced or no services at all it
means only 11 percent of the country's
rail services will be operating today
with many finishing early
so just get a bit more on this I'm
joined Now by Sky correspondent Matthew
Thompson who's at Houston Station in
central London for us so Matthew talk us
through it then are any trains leaving
hardly any at all I mean the scale of
this strike is unlike anything we've
seen for several years some people even
saying decades tens of thousands of
Railway staff as you've just pointed out
from four different unions uniting for
this 24-hour walkout which essentially
is bringing 90 percent of the country's
rail services to a complete standstill
in some parts of the country there will
just be no trains whatsoever a major
arterial routes from places like here
where I am in London Houston to cities
like Birmingham to Manchester to
Edinburgh simply not running at all
already this morning I've spoken to a
number of people who've turned up
confused and stranded at a rather
deserted Houston uh trying to get North
to places like Birmingham one man trying
to get work to work who are very
frustrated it is of course also the
London Marathon tomorrow people coming
from all over the world to attend that
to find that today their attempts to get
into London will be severely stymy but
of course the central Target of this
strike action is the Conservative Party
Conference which is taking place in
Birmingham this week that is a stated
intent from some of the strike
organizers they want to Target the
conservatives this is of course part of
a long-running dispute between the
government train operators Network Rail
and staff the conditions the the reasons
are well rehearsed pay conditions
largely in relation to a demand from
some of the unions for uh pay Rises to
be commensurate with inflation and the
fact of the matter is there's slim
chance seemingly of this being resolved
anytime soon and as you alluded to more
strike action to come with days already
scheduled for the 5th and 8th of October
Matthew thanks very much indeed
the Prime Minister has acknowledged for
the first time that there had been
disruption to the UK economy Following
last week's mini budget Liz truss
defended the decision to press ahead
with her economic plans without an
accompanying forecast from the office
for Budget responsibility saying it was
due to the need to respond rapidly to
Rising Energy prices
I recognize there has been disruption it
was really really important that we were
able to get help to families as soon as
possible that help is coming this
weekend because this is going to be a
difficult winter and I'm determined to
do all I can to help families and help
the economy at this time
well let's talk a little bit about the
past week politically joining me now is
former Communications advisor at Downing
Street to Theresa May and her
predecessor David Cameron Robin Gordon
Farley very good morning to you thanks
so much for talking to us here this
morning
let's start with a bit of an overview if
you and Liz truss coms person now how
would you be feeling after the week
we've had
well I think I think the first thing is
probably we can safely say the honeymoon
period is over and she's only been prime
minister for three weeks so I think that
will be that will be quite a major
troubling uh uh concern
um to uh Communications people in
Downing Street I think I think the
um you know clearly clearly that they
are changing changing tax slightly and
now the prime minister is now admitting
that you know that there has there has
been short-term disruption because so
that certainly hasn't been the line that
ministers have been saying up to this
point
um and uh she's repeated that not only
in the clip you just played but but
she's also repeated that in a piece that
she's written in the in the Sun
newspaper today so I think in terms of
you know going into now the Party
Conference
um it's certainly not not the best
backdrop for for them to be going into
the Party Conference
would it have helped if she'd have
spoken out sooner she did do that round
of local radio interviews on Thursday
didn't she and and that didn't play so
well for her but but but for general
advice should she have been out and
about more giving interviews
yeah I think I think I think um I mean I
think let's trust as a potato self but
you know she's not the slickest of
politicians when it comes to
presentation I think you know those
those Regional radio uh interviews that
you've mentioned uh
what
we're really a complete car Crasher I
mean I don't think you can say anything
else but that um so um I I think I think
in terms of um in terms of acknowledging
the situation I mean they're starting to
acknowledge that that the the fiscal
statement that they did has has made um
some some type of disruptions but but up
to that up to that point they haven't
acknowledged that at all um and as if it
as if as if there was no impact at all
so you know I think I think when there's
a lot of worry in
um about people's bills and yes it's
great that the government has set out
set out plans to help help with energy
bills and clearly that's what they want
to be pushing is that the fact that they
have acted swiftly
um you can't deny it now that there's
people worried about about mortgages
with interest rates
um continuing to arise so I think in
terms of a real need
um for for the government
um and uh to really set out their
narrative now to really start explaining
uh and I think probably we're starting
to see a little bit of a shift now with
starting to acknowledge that the about
the the disruption that has been caused
well yes and we've seen articles also
not just Liz trust but also the
chancellor of course equate is written
in the telegraph the leveling up
secretary Simon Clark has written in the
times and what do you make of the kind
of reassurance that's going out there so
quasi-quarting obviously seeking to
reassure the markets saying yes we're
spending a lot of money we're borrowing
a lot uh because of the energy support
package and because of all the tax cuts
we've now promised but the sums will add
up don't worry we're going to rein in
spending and that that may reach all the
markets it may not but that's obviously
the intention but it's also what does
that do to the public when they think
spending carts we've got Simon Clark
talking about trimming the fat and a
generous welfare state system you know
what what impact could this have on the
public that message
yeah I think I mean I think it's really
confusing because because what we're
getting is is a is a real Focus from the
government about we've got to do things
differently and we've and it's a
Relentless pursuit of growth
um but then they're not they're not
they're not adding all the numbers
behind that in terms of so I think in
terms of the markets the markets have
been completely spooked which has been
pretty clear from from the get-go
um and there was no numbers behind it
and I think I think that that has been
that has been an error that has taken
place so so you know what the public are
seeing is now is now you know newspapers
and and on their TVs is is is is
basically an economy economy in crisis
so I I think I think I think what's
what's what's going to be really
important now is that they really do
have to start to set out quite quite a
comprehensive narrative about what we're
going to do because what what it does
feel and it looks and it looks like
Department government departments are
being asked to come up with with
spending cuts
bit by bit we're hearing and getting
clues really that it looks like looks
like the benefit system is going to is
going to face
um quite a squeeze now if we look at the
tax cuts that have been announced
they're not going to they're not
potentially going to be helping people
on benefits and if we look at the amount
of people on Universal Credit you know
let's not forget if you're on if you're
on the universe of credit doesn't mean
that you're unemployed it means you you
are employed um and you and you're
getting topped up with with Universal
Credit and the problem there is that is
that some of those people will be below
the tax tax cut threshold so I think I
think I think they really need and I
think if we look ahead to the Party
Conference next week we've got the
chancellor on Monday
um doing his his address to the
conference and then obviously the Prime
Minister on Wednesday
um I I would imagine that's been
Rewritten uh quite quite quite a bit so
I think there needs to be a lot of
reassuring tones they need to really now
start to set out how this is all going
to stack up because I don't
I I think I think I think it's going to
be a hard ask and the government's going
to be on under human humongous pressure
now that to wait now until the 23rd of
November when the when the chancellor
sets out his next fiscal statement
um to see the obr forecast and and see
all of that so I think I think now it's
going to be a real
a real reassuring job and they
definitely need to start
um reconnecting uh with with the public
on this because we are seeing now uh the
polls come in uh and you know uh the the
shock poll from yougov this week with
labor now 33 point lead ahead of the
conservative party uh is a real
indication that you've got some real
problems that you need to fix pretty
quickly yeah it's going to be really
interesting to see how that conference
plays out doesn't it
um Robin Gordon Farley really
interesting to get your take on it all
thanks very much indeed thank you
let's go to Westminster now political
correspondent Rob Powell is there and
listening in and Rob reflecting there on
the government deciding really to do a
little bit of explaining a little bit of
reassurance yeah definitely the focus
and uh as Robin was saying there in the
pieces by various government ministers
and the prime minister in the papers
this morning first of all I think trying
to trumpet the energy help that kicks in
from today you'll remember that was
announced in the Commons by Liz truss on
the day uh the queen passed away so it
was somewhat uh sort of blotted out by
that and I think since the mini budget
has been somewhat eclipsed by the
turmoil of the last seven days as well
so that's one part of it and then as you
were discussing there I think very much
reassurance and explanation is the
second part of that one part though of
that reassurance you do wonder whether
it's going to prove to be a double-edged
sword because the chancellor quasi
quateng has talked about bringing
um spending on assist sustainable
footing and explaining how that will
happen when he sets out a statement in
November
but I think probably the most
significant intervention we've had this
morning is an interview that Simon Clark
has given to the Times newspaper now
Simon Clark is leveling up secretary
he's someone that is quite close to this
trust someone that is in a kind of core
group of ministers that is behind Liz
truss's approach to the economy and in
this interview with the times he has
talked about how his big concern is that
in Western Europe we are living in a
Fool's Paradise where we can be less
productive and still think that we have
a very large welfare state he says the
two are not compatible and also says
that it's important that we look at a
state which is extremely large and look
at how we can make sure that is in full
alignment with a lower tax economy you
can see the headline in the times there
trust Ally prepares UK for new age of
austerity I think many MPS and perhaps
many voters will be looking at comments
like that and especially the mention
specifically of benefits and think this
does sound an awful lot like spending
cuts an awful lot like austerity the
years that we went through when David
Cameron was prime minister and I think
Tory MPS will be wondering how they
square that how they Square tax cuts for
people earning over 150 000 pounds with
potentially benefits not keeping Pace
with inflation and how they Square the
fact that government departments will be
needing to trim the fat as Simon Clark
puts it at a time when demand is high
you take a department like the ministry
of justice that runs the courts and the
court backlog and the issues we've had
around legal aid recently a lot of
Public Services people will say need
more investment not less right now and
how MPS sort of square that political
Circle if you like
over the coming years if it is that we
are entering a period of sustained
spending cuts might be quite difficult
for them
Rob thanks very much
well also making the news this morning
Buckingham Palace has received more than
50 000 letters and messages expressing
The public's condolences following the
Queen's death the royal family has been
flooded with mail from well-wishers who
felt moved to write and convey their
Sympathy for the monarch
consumers are being warned they may be
targeted by scammers as the government's
energy price guarantee comes into effect
today the business secretary Jacob
reese-mogg issued the warning and said
that messages asking for people to
provide personal or financial details
should be treated as fraudulent activity
Iran's intelligence Ministry says nine
European Nationals have been arrested
during deadly Street protests sparked by
a custody death Intelligence Officers
reportedly detained people deemed to be
agents of foreign spy organizations
either protests or behind the scenes
thousands of Iranians have taken to the
streets over the last few weeks
following the death of a 22 year old
woman who'd been detained by the police
for allegedly wearing her headscarf too
loosely
so far
Moscow and the West have traded blows
once more following Russia's annexation
of four regions of Ukraine following
referendums dismissed as shammed by the
International Community Vladimir Putin
attacked the West as satanic and told
citizens in occupied regions of Ukraine
that they were now his citizens forever
Ukraine has responded by formally
submitting an application for NATO
membership as Western countries
condemned the land grab our Moscow
correspondent Diana magnet was in
moscow's red square and sent this report
[Applause]
he was always going to show up to claim
these new territories which are not his
to declare to his people that Russia
will be victorious in what he's pitched
as an existential battle for the
motherland harass
[Applause]
and of course these crowds cheered him
off that's what they were here for
[Applause]
the fight in Ukraine has not been going
that well for Vladimir Putin and his
call for partial mobilization has shown
significant cracks in the edifice of
Russian patriotism he needs this moment
he needs to try and tell his people that
their fight is worth it
the day had all the Pomp and ceremony of
a formal process treaties signed solemn
Talk of the right to self-determination
in the U.N Charter but make no mistake
there is no legal basis to what Russia
has done
I want the key of authorities and their
real Masters in the west to hear me so
that everyone will remember it people
living in lahansk Donetsk Curson and
zaporiza have become our citizens
forever
that's not how Ukraine sees it or the
West which immediately slapped fresh
sanctions on Putin's regime but his
invective tirade against the West is
contagious patriotic Russians draped in
their flag proclaiming a kind of
reworked Soviet Union filled with a cold
war style Fury
you won't defeat us we are one nation
for sure Russians belarusians ukrainians
shuvash mordovians all of them are
Russians against you we will defeat you
you will never win not on your life
this is the protection of our national
interests the fight for our state's
existence its prosperity and greatness
and in red square they cheered their
commander-in-chief a man who keeps
raising the stakes in an Ever more
dangerous conflict Diana magnney Sky
News Moscow
while following the Russian president's
speech the condemnation has been Swift
NATO Chief yens stoltenberg said Putin's
actions represent the most serious
escalation since the start of the war
Russia vetoed a U.N security Council
resolution condemning the annexation and
U.S President Joe Biden issued this
Stark warning
America is fully prepared prepared with
our NATO allies to defend every single
inch of NATO territory
every single and so Mr Putin don't
misunderstand what I'm saying every inch
particularly now with the weather's day
warm memories wherever you go
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
well we're in for a breezy weekend with
some scattered blustery showers it could
turn gray and wet in Southern England I
want to keep an eye out for the London
Marathon tomorrow brisk wins this
morning will bring a mixture of bright
spells and showers it'll be windiest in
the Northwest with Coastal Gales overall
it's going to be a Blustery Day with
sunny spells and scattered showers the
showers will be heaviest and most
frequent in the west Cloud meanwhile
will build along the South Coast
bringing some patchy rain to Devon and
Cornwall
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
to turn now to the first of three rounds
of rail strikes scheduled for this month
at the biggest biggest of its kind for a
generation join me now is the
spokesperson for the rail delivery Group
which represents the rail companies Dan
Paynes a very good morning to you thanks
so much for talking to us this morning
and how badly hit will the network be by
these strikes just what level of service
will you be able to offer well this is
probably the biggest level of disruption
that we've seen in this series of
disputes so far we've normally been able
to run around 20 to 50 percent of rail
Services when there's been a strike
before but this time we've got all three
unions we've got the tssa we've got the
rmt and we've got asleff that are going
out at the same time in this coordinated
action and that means probably only
around 11 of trained Services across the
country will be running and some areas
of the network won't have any train
services at all well the rmt for example
have said that its decision to hold
further strikes come about because no
further offers from the rail industry to
help come to a negotiated settlement are
there so so what is the latest on the
office on the table and the progress of
negotiations
well first of all let me apologize to
any of our customers and your viewers
who are disrupted by uh today and have
had to change their Journeys our focus
is on getting a deal that allows us to
give our people the pay rise we want to
give them a fair pay Rise
um while also making sure that we've got
a railway that is fit for the future and
that means delivering reforms that
deliver us the savings and the customer
improvements to make that pay rise
possible
okay well let's let's look at those two
different things the pay rise firstly
rail workers say that they want a wage
rise in line with inflation they say
that's only fair
well I'm certainly not going to come
here and say our staff don't deserve a
pay rise yeah the talks that we've been
having now certainly in the last four or
five months have been designed to give
them exactly that but the railway itself
is in a difficult financial position uh
as well we're coming out of the pandemic
which took our rail passenger numbers to
almost zero with you know almost no
Revenue at all and while workers and
staff at train operators across the
country have brought that back up to
around 80 percent of where we used to be
that's still a pretty big black hole to
to deliver the pay rise that we want to
deliver so that means we've got to look
at ways of doing things differently
bringing ourselves in line with
customers in 2022 and matching their
behaviors and that's a different
position for us to be in so we need to
get to that point and that's why we're
continuing to have those discussions
with those trade unions but but as far
as payers concerned Mick Lynch and the
rmt for example would say that companies
are actually managing to extract big
profits he says the bosses of those
companies are earning huge salaries
which just got even bigger because of
the mini budget they'll end up with uh
bonuses of kind of 50 to 60 000 pounds
because of the scrapping of the 45p high
tax rate they say it's a bit Rich
basically for those at the top of the
companies to be doing so well but
denying uh Railway workers lower down in
the pecking order an inflationary pay
rise
well yeah most of the time that the
unions use these figures they're
actually using figures quoted from from
companies that own some of those train
operates it's not the train operators
themselves and that obviously involves
different operations often in different
countries and different modes of
Transport so it's not right to make that
case what I can say and what the rmt
seem to be saying is that look actually
if you took all the profits from the
train operators you could be able to to
pay deliver this pay rise without any
reforms at all and that's just not true
even if we gave all of our colleagues
across the whole of the industry a five
percent pay rise the profits of the
train operators would only cover half of
that so we're going to have to look at
reform whatever sort of operation that
the railway industry is under to not
only deliver this pay rise but also to
make sure that we're in a position as an
industry to deliver for our customers
today there's been a lot of change in
the last two or three years in terms of
customer habits uh and behaviors and EXP
expectations so that commuter level of
service those season ticket holders that
you know with a Bedrock of the
industry's finances three or four years
ago just aren't there anymore but there
is an opportunity in Leisure Travel
people that uh I I see we're seeing
growth in train operators across the
country in those Leisure markets but the
railway actually isn't that geared up to
delivering those in the way and growing
those in the way that we would like to
which is another reason you know that we
need to look at the way we do things
you talk about modernization the union
say that you're asking for safety
standards to be diluted so that
companies can make bigger profits we'll
never ever compromise on safety at all
and that's just not true I mean even you
know if you look at the areas that
they're talking about there in
particular which is you know some of the
network rail maintenance regimes Network
rail is a a fully nationalized industry
it hasn't got any profits to make or
shareholders to please at all and even
from a railway company perspective
nowadays all of the revenue that comes
in from from passengers goes straight to
the government and train operators have
paid a small fixed fee uh for for
managing the railway so that equation
which might have been true in the past
just isn't there anymore
okay and and on the subject of you were
apologizing to passengers I'm sure
people are frustrated not being able to
to catch trains today however is there a
sense do you think that the public mood
might be in support of the people going
out on strike today there'll be a lot of
people in this country that are also
really worried about Rising inflation
and and fear that their own wages won't
keep up with it they might have a real
sympathy for striking rail workers today
well if I'm when I'm out and about on
the railway I see both sides of of that
argument of course there are people that
will you know support the strikes and of
course there are people that don't like
being disrupted and would rather they
were able to get on with their you know
Journeys whether that's a care worker or
a nurse going into work shift workers
who have all been disrupted today so
there is a of course a range of opinions
but from a rail industry perspective all
we want to do is get in there and get a
deal that works for our customers that
works for our colleagues and the works
for the taxpayer
okay well Dan Payne spokesperson for the
rail delivery group thanks very much
indeed and just let everyone know we
will be talking to Mick Lynch from the
rmt in about an hour's time so we'll get
his take on on the strikes going on
today
but right now we're going to turn our
attention to Florida where at least 27
people are known to have died in the
passage of hurricane Ian the authorities
fear that the number May in fact be
considerably higher cleaning up from the
devastation will run into billions of
dollars Sky's Martha Kellner reports now
on the damage on Sanibel Island in
Florida
good work hey Florida's Emergency
Services know what the days after a
hurricane are like they know time is of
the essence for those awaiting rescue
but even for the most wisened the Damage
Done by Hurricane Ian is startling
it's the barrier islands off the state's
southwest coast that bore the brunt of
it this is Sanibel Island where the Rich
and Famous come on holiday few parts
escaped the Wrath of the storm
the causeway the only Road on or off
this island is impassable
rescues can only be made by boat Sanibel
firefighters have borrowed a pleasure
Cruise
as hurricane Ian was making landfall
hundreds of people on Sanibel Island
were making calls to Emergency Services
to report this incredible level of water
that they were experiencing what you see
now is these emergency service Personnel
making their way onto the island to try
and go to those addresses to check if
people have managed to survive and here
you see some of those who they have
managed to rescue
Murray Lou lives on the north of the
island she's walked four miles climbing
over fell trees to get here
the Water started coming in
and within
five minutes the water was nine feet in
the house
and I was up on the third floor right
I sheltered in a closet until part of
the roof came off
and then the wind came in there so then
I just went behind the bed
and stayed there
I know
we're lucky to be alive yeah do you feel
do you feel that I do I do and I I will
never ever ever
not evacuate again how long have you
lived on on son of Belgrade uh 35 years
wow seven hurricanes I've been through
never been like this
this is like an apom hit this place
I was in Vietnam 68 69. this is what it
reminds me of
first they took off my roof then I took
off my upper staircase and the only
thing I have left now is my two bedrooms
in the back and I had my cats in the
bedrooms with me and that was it I had
nothing else
as Rich who is blind is being reunited
with his family the mayor of Sanibel
greets survivors
been a short Journey Back to the
mainland but for many it represents the
before and the after they don't know
when or if they'll ever return home
Martha Kellner Sky News Sanibel Island
so let's go through some of the morning
papers now with me this morning are the
UK editor of the big issue Paul McNamee
and international business Expert Alison
Stuart Allen welcome back to both of you
we dealt with a lot of the front pages
didn't we in the last hour so we're
going to delve inside at this time
around and Paul you found an article in
the express first of all talking about
some of the pressures on nurses in
particular I think
yes this is something that um the
express picked up from the BBC and it is
looking at the novel trust identified
that 40 000 nurses have quit in the last
year that's one in nine
um of nurses in Britain a lot of
experience particularly
um experienced nurses leaving and this
is a lot of what they're important here
is because of a work-like balance and
the pressures they're feeling and
um trying to find some way to to get
through days and we know the pressures
that nurses in healthcare
Specialists were put under particularly
during covert trying to save so many
lives so I suppose it's not a surprise
but what is difficult is to see how The
Replacements are going to come this is
we're about to hit the 80th anniversary
of a beverage report when the NHS was
first really
um conceived from that idea of cradle
degree of care
feels as though it is ebbing away but
Simon Clark talking quite Leafly about
tax cuts and suggesting and the
implication being that taking tax cuts
out to make a smaller State as if
there's a lot of people on the make
trying to get money but the money is
needed for this very thing to recruit
nurses the pay nurses properly to keep
everything going the average nurse
salary starting salary is 25 Grand
which isn't that much when you consider
what they need to do for us so there is
it's an identifiable crisis
we don't know exactly what brexit is
caused in terms of people coming into
nursing from overseas there is there's a
major problem and just another thing
that the trust government are going to
have to really deal with but it doesn't
look as though they're going to do it by
bringing money in from tax revenues yeah
we'll have to we'll have to wait and see
I think we will get more details
obviously in in the months ahead
certainly by the end of November that
November 23rd date on that in the
meantime Allison you're taking us in a
different direction via an electric
vehicle I believe
absolutely so there's a new UK startup
uh that is doing electric vans uh and
the reason this is newsworthy uh is
because they have uh several orders
already from UPS uh and it's quite an
innovation to be able to have an
electric van uh doing deliveries uh it
cuts emissions uh it's a lot more uh
eco-friendly uh but what's Innovative is
that this bister micro Factory uh is in
fact a a novelty because of the way it
assembles the parts uh it has a just in
time approach to the assembly process
and it's another Great British story of
innovation you know this country is full
of them uh and I think we don't
celebrate that really enough about just
the incredible Talent here uh to be able
to do things like this uh the other
aspect of this is the international
appeal uh you know I think there are not
any other countries anywhere in the
world that are doing electric vans that
can turn them out at this pace uh and
sort of a global market like uh a rival
can so uh and the name arrival uh is
actually really good it sounds like
rival uh but I think they are destined
for great things so uh it's a very good
story oh well there's a a real uh seal
of approval there from Alison for that
and uh nice to get some positive news I
guess so I haven't had very much of that
around have we but Paul you've got a
story in the express haven't you about
and older people wanting a return of
face-to-face banking
yes and can I just say on electric vans
just to support Allison was saying in
terms of green I guess you're switching
to a fleet of electric fans we're
working with Citroen together all of the
magazines across Britain so we're with
you Alison yes on in the express I don't
think I've ever said Express so much as
I have this morning but this is a story
um it's an age UK war and it says all
their customers
um want to return to bank tellers
um a2k want to put pressure they found
that up to three quarters they say of
all their customers want face-to-face
banking for a whole set of reasons that
it you know wouldn't be too hard to work
out if they let it particular times in
life when there's been a bereavement for
instance it's better to face to face the
deal with the estate or they just want
to put make deposits or take cash
withdrawals there's still a lot of cash
being used and it's felt that perhaps
online banking isn't always the answer
but the interesting part I think is that
the um educator demanding amendments in
the financial services and markets Bill
and that is to protect asking the
government to guarantee they will
protect physical post offices and Banks
which
you know you you could argue well you
know this is the way that the world is
going every everything is moving
cashless but
I can see that they may get some cut
through and that's because of if the
conservative party looked to their their
demographic and they see that over 65
are more likely to vote for them perhaps
that particular thing will be a bonus
for us all because it will mean more
post office and Banks stay open yeah
interesting one uh in the daily mail
um Allison you've seen a story about
bereaved families possibly being able to
get access to their children's profiles
talk us through this one
yeah well there's pending legislation
obviously uh with the uh here in the UK
uh to
um oversee if you like and regulate uh
online platforms uh and sparked by this
Molly Russell case uh which is
incredibly tragic that the family have
been uh waiting five years to get
information about uh the feed and the
algorithms that fed Molly Russell this
diet of harmful content uh and it's
looking now as if families will be able
to crack open this Vault uh that the
social media platforms have uh so uh you
know
persistently protected uh so that
families can see what their children
have been looking at uh and I think
Trent this is uh a transparency measure
uh that should have come five six years
ago but you know I guess better late
than never
so this is good news for families who uh
are concerned rightly about what these
platforms are serving up uh and the more
transparency and the more light that is
shed on how uh companies and Brands
online or offline how they operate uh
this has to be a good thing